this week is what Donald Trump is
calling infrastructure week it's sort of
an attempt to distract Americans from
the worsening Russia scandal and the
endless attempts to do anything within
his administration bigger picture though
I've been telling you for a while that
Donald Trump's version of infrastructure
plans are really just privatization and
crony capitalists handout plans and
that's exactly what we're seeing in his
latest proposal which is the
privatization of air traffic control
take a look at this yesterday making a
big deal out of shaking hands and
signing a deal to privatize air traffic
control at airports around the world
this is sort of a conservative dream
almost no other country in the world has
a fully private air traffic control
system the White House official who has
been pushing for this move is Trump's
chief economic adviser Gary cone former
president and CEO of none other than
goldman sachs drained the swamp right
our air traffic control system has the
crucially important task of controlling
American airspace currently it's
operated by the Federal Aviation
Administration there has not been a
fatal crash of a domestic passenger
airliner in eight years
statistically flying in the u.s. is
safer than it has ever been and to give
you a sense of how safe American
commercial aviation is not a single
person even died on an airplane crash in
a u.s. certified scheduled airline
operating anywhere in the world and part
of that is because of air traffic
control in 2016 we're talking about 300
airport towers and flight tracking
centers 35,000 workers 14,000
controllers 6,000 technicians major
operation right Trump wants to hand it
all over to a private corporation which
don't worry it'll be a nonprofit
corporation that at least with the
privatization of ATC you're not
siphoning off public funds to go to it
so for example when we talk about
charter schools or private prisons yeah
taxpayers are still paying for those
with the ATC it'll just be reflected in
airline ticket yes and no yes you owe
you'll pay more
for it in airline tickets there's no
doubt about it but you would still be
transferring all of those assets to the
private sector and who paid for those
assets originally it was taxpayers that
is a gift to these companies so yes
you're right on an operational ongoing
basis you stop using taxpayer money but
we're talking about endless billions of
dollars in infrastructure here you go
here have it private corporation take it
yeah it still is not a good thing one of
those things that you would want to be a
public good yeah and not one that you
would think a prophet sent incentive
would make sense for and the way that
Pat points out the the proposal from
Trump would be that this private air
traffic control would be funded by
individual airlines and the
corporation's board member positions
would be held by representatives of
those airlines let's think about that
for a second second it makes it certain
that this ATC corporation would be
dominated by a small group of the
largest and most politically influential
companies and groups you're basically
turning the ATC into a corporate board
for big airlines who by the way have
been lobbying for this to happen since
the 1980s why because it would give them
the power to prioritize their companies
when it comes to controlling air traffic
now the AOPA which is the aircraft
owners and Pilots Association largest
aviation Association in the world
they're staunchly against this for many
reasons one of which is that it will be
the death of non commercial aviation
if you privatize ATC it would result in
pilots paying usage fees per flight
which is usually sort of an integral
part of these private ATC systems
elsewhere in the world this is like if
the roads were owned by one company and
every time you got in your car and
wanted to drive on a road you had to pay
them because they control the traffic
lights and street signs in a way it's
sort of like toll roads yeah but if the
toll roads were owned or managed not by
a state but rather by a private
corporation this is the biggest ruse and
by the way the entire delay thing that
we hear about I recently talked about
United Airlines saying we've got to
modernize ATC
and maybe privatize ATC because ATC is
responsible for delays and the Trump
administration said the same thing if we
privatize we're going to drastically
reduce flight delays total and utter
nonsense
there are basically two causes for
delays weather which we can't change and
Airlines the very people who would be
running this private version of air
traffic control it is such a ruse pad
but you hear about trumpets who love
this they say yes we want to privatize
yeah we want to privatize because
private industry does everything better
than the government but I think most
Trump supporters when they went to the
polls to cast their ballot they were not
voting on this issue I will no it's not
a voting issue it's not a voting issue
but it's one that many trumpets will see
as a sort of accomplishment of sorts for
Donald Trump he privatized something
privatization is not necessary it's not
necessary to modernize ATC which is also
something we hear about they've got old
radar systems we need new radar systems
so we'll privatize hold on a second the
process of going from public to private
is going to take years during that time
there will be no modernization of ATC if
and when the transition is completed
from public to private then you can
start talking about modernization
something that the FAA is already
working on so you're actually just going
to further delay that it's absolutely
bogus there is going to be a lack of
oversight here does anyone who has flown
recently think that airlines are
efficient and competent enough to run
all of air traffic control when all non
weather-related delays depend on them
when they constantly are deferring
maintenance on airplanes to the absolute
maximum and in the case of United in one
case that we recently learned about
beyond the maximum for safety I don't
want this going private Donald Trump
does and the the I guess Pat we can hope
that the free market works things out
right you might have a few airplane
crashes but then it'll really
incentivize these companies to get their
stuff together with the private ATC yeah
and if you remember with that United
incident they tried to blame air traffic
control for Wright happen there
going to be a lot harder to do what this
has taken over by private industry yeah
when you control air traffic control all
of a sudden it's harder to blame air
traffic control as this disconnected
entity from the government that's
causing all of your problems disaster
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman send me your
thoughts about the privatization of ATC